buonasera togliere la memoria è una
persona e come svuotarla come rubarle
l'identità e prima di venire alta dex di
lecce lo sapevamo già per esempio
guardando salvator dalì nel suo quadro i
cassetti della memoria
ma dove sono questi cassetti della
memoria e sono davvero dei cassetti
davvero mettere degli episodi della
nostra vita e memoria un po come riporre
dei maglioncini o dei calzini in un
sistema con tanti cassetti partiamo
proprio dall'inizio quando si forma la
nostra identità individuale
all'inizio noi siamo un tubo di tubo
neurale che ha varie zone visto in
sezione e il primo evento che ci accade
dopo circa quattro settimane dal
concepimento in termine tecnico si
chiama eva jin azione
vuol dire che della parte anteriore del
tubo neurale si estroflettono vengono in
fuori quelli che sono gli inizi dei due
emisferi cerebrali poi l'embrione
continua a svilupparsi nel corso delle
settimane questa parte anteriore del
tubo neurale i due misteri vengono a
crescere sproporzionatamente sempre di
più fino a che nell'individuo adulto
visto in una sezione simile naturalmente
a scala diversa abbiamo che gran parte
del nostro cervello è diventato quello
che noi chiamiamo corteccia cerebrale si
è una parte che viene da da una certa a
porzione del tubo neurale essenzialmente
è tutta un sistema che ha a che fare con
la memoria però dentro questo sistema di
memoria che occupa la gran parte del
nostro sistema nervoso
c'è un pezzo particolare
è il pezzo che si sviluppa a partire
dalla sezione in rosso del nostro tubo
neurale è quello che nell'individuo
adulto diventa l'ippocampo
adesso come che siamo diventati
in sostanza delle macchine per la
memoria
allora per capirlo partiamo ancora più
indietro
partiamo dalla creazione da tutti tutte
le spese create dalla potente ci
possiamo chiedere com'è che fra tutte
queste specie da tutte queste specie
siamo venuti fuori noi non è stato un
processo casuale da einstein sappiamo
che l'onnipotente non gioca a dadi
ma sono stati in sostanza altri due
giochi
una è il gioco delle tre carte e quando
fra le tre classi di vertebrati avanzati
i rettili e mammiferi e gli uccelli
l'onnipotente ha scelto i mammiferi e
poi in una fase successiva milioni di
anni dopo
fra tutte le specie di mammiferi si è
differenziata la specie umana con
caratteristiche precipue del sistema
nervoso e delle capacità della mente
allora possiamo raffigurarci questi due
processi in una maniera molto
semplificata schematica in questo
diagramma dove ho messo la struttura in
una dimensione la funzione nell'altro è
la prima cosa che succede è che i
mammiferi in rosso si distinguono dai
reti e dagli uccelli in blu e in verde e
qui il tempo va verso l'alto poi però se
continuiamo e cerchiamo di capire
commessi differenziano le varie specie
di nomi ferì è come se l'albero si
piegasse e il tempo adesso
valente verso destra perché questo lo
capiamo andando a guardare dentro il
cervello queste sono sezioni nel
cervello di sei diverse specie di
mammiferi quello che in cui ci
riconosciamo che di gran lunga il più
simile a noi è il maiale al centro in
basso ci sembrano diverse perché
cambiano degli aspetti in realtà
superficiali ci sono alcuni cervelli che
hanno molte più circonvoluzioni e solchi
e altri che sono più liscia però la loro
struttura interna la loro
l'organizzazione dei circuiti neurali in
particolare della memoria è la stessa in
tutti i mammiferi e questo lo vediamo
confrontando con invece una sezione di
un cervello di un rettile una lucertola
adesso vedete l'attenzione su questa
porzione della corteccia interna della
lucertola uno strato di cellule come
pallini in nero nei mammiferi qui è una
sezione di un di un cervello di
ornitorinco questa semplice strato di
cellule diventa una cosa di più
complessa ci sono come queste due c che
si facciano l'una con l'altra sembra il
logo di gucci
questo è l'ippocampo di un ornitorinco
che ha in sostanza lo stesso
dell'ippocampo di un ratto o di un gatto
o di un uomo
abbiamo tutti lo stesso ippocampo e le
diversa da quello dei rettili degli
uccelli un'altra parte della corteccia
la parte dorsale nella ricerca di nuove
un semplice e strato di cellule in un
mammifero come ad esempio in una china
diventa un sistema multi multistrato
quindi sia l'ippocampo che la corteccia
cerebrale sono diverse nei mammiferi
rispetto a quello che erano né rettili e
sono diversi anche dagli uccelli
è come se la differenziazione dei
mammiferi dei redditi degli uccelli
fosse una differenziazione un salto di
nella struttura del sistema nervoso c'è
una nuova struttura come un nuovo
microchip invece la funzione non cambia
con un salto così drammatico cambia
continuatamente questa la transizione
verso i mammiferi
quando poi si differenziano le varie
specie di mammiferi e abbiamo i vari
cervelli dei mammiferi
abbiamo una situazione opposta abbiamo
cervelli che variano si nelle dimensioni
come potete vedere quello più in alto e
cervello umano però la struttura interna
è sempre la stessa anche se ci sono
delle ovvie differenze funzionali c'è un
salto funzionale almeno fra gli umani e
le altre specie di mammiferi
allora se la struttura è la stessa
possiamo cercare di capire come la
memoria funziona sulla base di questa
struttura possiamo cercare di capire
andando avanti sulla strada che è stata
aperta da brenda milner 60 anni fa
studiando pazienti cerebrolesi
in particolare il paziente più famoso
anremo la son era questo signore che per
essere curato di un'epilessia
particolarmente intrattabile ha subito
si usava in quegli anni una lobotomia
vedete che nel diagramma a sinistra è il
cervello di ecm rim all azione dopo la
lobotomia manca tutto un pezzo che è il
lobo temporale include l'ippocampo lui è
rimasto una persona gioviale sorridente
intelligente come era prima di subire
questa lobotomia però è diventato un
messico ha completamente perso la
memoria la capacità di ricordare le cose
che succedevano nella vita di tutti i
giorni ha mantenuto alcune dei ricordi
dopo forse me ne sentiremo parlare di un
altro caso diverso ma analogo a questo
ha mantenuto alcuni ricordi degli anni
remoti della sua infanzia ma ha avuto
un'amnesia completa del degli episodi e
delle cose che mi sono successe negli
anni dalla lesione e fino a quanto ha
vissuto che si è morto poco tempo fa il
fatto che la struttura del sistema
nervoso che si occupa della memoria
l'ippocampo è anche il resto della
corteccia cerebrale siano abbiano la
stessa organizzazione nell'uomo e nelle
altre specie di mammiferi permette di
andare avanti sulla strada tracciata da
brenda milner spostandosi su specie
nelle quali è possibile e facile andare
dentro il cervello e dentro l'ippocampo
la struttura in rosa in un roditore nel
diagramma in basso e dentro vediamo
quella struttura interna con questa
doppia c e colorato in particolare è
questa regione che è così particolare il
giro dentato di cui non ho tempo di
raccontarvi le caratteristiche
sorprendenti
però vi posso dire in una slide cosa
fanno queste cellule del giro tentato lo
sappiamo
dagli studi di john o'keefe che ha avuto
il premio nobel nel 2014 e che ha
studiato cosa fanno i neuroni
nell'ippocampo di un fatto quando il
ratto semplicemente cammina
nell'ambiente e quello che ha visto è
che ci sono neuroni che rappresentano
ciascuno una posizione nell'ambiente il
neurone si attiva quando il ratto passa
attraverso una specifica posizione
dell'ambiente
questa posizione però non è non è stata
assegnata a quel neurone dal codice
genetico come abbiamo sentito prima o
non li viene dal da doverli euron e
dentro il circuito è una assegnazione
casuale è come se a ciascun neuroni
dell'ippocampo venisse assegnata una
parte per rappresentare quello che sta
succedendo all'animale il neurone come
un attore e gli dice tu adesso ti occupi
di rappresentare questo questi neuroni
dell'ippocampo devono rappresentare il
fatto che l'animale in quel momento di
tempo si trovi in una certa posizione
che è diversa da un neurone a neurone
adesso questo capacità dell'ippocampo di
distribuire i suoi neuroni come attori
per mettere in scena qualcosa che sta
succedendo all'animale è la base del
ruolo dell ippocampo nella memoria delle
memorie si formano nell'ippocampo perché
nella corteccia non si potrebbero
depositare così rapidamente le
esperienze come noi le viviamo
allora vengono assegnate a ciascuna
esperienza una rappresentazione una
specie di dramma che viene svolto nell
ippocampo da attori i neuroni che si
prestano a questo e che poi lo
rappresentano
alla corteccia a tutte le altre zone
della corteccia tante e tante volte fino
a che la memoria si consolida nella
corteccia quelle memorie che vale la
pena vs che vale la pena di
rappresentare perché l'individuale vuole
ricordare allora questa immagine che ne
esce da questa
da questi studi è quella di una memoria
nella corteccia che non è un semplice
golfino riposto in un cassetto è un
qualche cosa di dinamico di cangiante
come i camembert gli orologi della
persistenza delle memorie di salvador
dalì la memoria è un qualche cosa che
ricaviamo ogni giorno godendosi lo
spettacolo che ci dà il nostro ippocampo
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]